[Music]
[Applause]
s capacho has been the Bills beat
reporter for wgr sports radio he has
covered the team for 13 years he's a
sideline reporter as well and he joins
us on the program sou thanks for getting
up and joining us um give me a sense of
what the feeling was in Buffalo leading
up to this game the confidence level
will you think that the bills and fan
base
had first of all it's a pleasure and
honor to join you Dan thanks for having
me um I would say it was cautiously
optimistic because we've seen the bills
bow out to the Kansas City Chiefs a
couple of times over the last three
years in the playoffs but those games
were in Kansas City now you get a chance
to have what appeared to be more of a
wounded kind of Kansas City team meaning
not the same Chiefs offense they've seem
more vulnerable and you had them here in
your house right where it's super loud
it's going to make it a tougher envir
environment so I think fans were
cautiously optimistic feeling good about
that but also knowing they were depleted
on defense with all the injuries and if
you can just kind of hold on for 60
minutes and make a few plays you're
going to the AFC Championship game I
think that was the feeling going in do
you think any changes are made sure
there's always changes big changes you
know this is a aging roster but it's
still got some good young Talent
obviously and Josh Allen is just into
the prime of his career right now um so
they're going to contend for a while but
you have to think about guys like Jordan
pyer and Micah Hyde and you know what
their future lies and Von Miller and
he's got a big contract but you know
coming off the injury he wasn't that
effective um this particular season but
if you're talking about front office
coaching changes there's a segment of
fans who definitely would tell you and
we take calls like this all the time on
my radio show Dan that say like hey sha
MC has been great has a culture changer
but maybe they've hit their ceiling
maybe they can't go any farther with him
but I'll be honest with you I I just I
don't see from my perspective that
ownership would do something like that
they love what they have in sha mcder
and Brandon Bean what they built here
they're contenders every year they want
a great program they have Synergy and
the owners the Terry and Kula also own
the hockey team in town which isn't
performing very well and they're trying
to put resources into that to try and
you know I don't think they want to have
both those things happening but you
never know nothing surprises me in this
business what do you think the level of
pain is today if you were going to
describe it to the rest of the
country um it's it's it's a it's up
there if it's a one through 10 it's
close to a 10 I mean listen it was a
little anticlimactic at the end it
wasn't like losing with 13 seconds left
when you thought you had it and were
going to the AFC Championship at home a
couple of years ago but still I mean I
think more than anything Dan this is a
big picture thing for this city you know
other than the AFL years in the 1960s
and the lacrosse team which is in town I
want to give them respect we've never
won a championship here with the Buffalo
Bills or Super Bowl or Stanley Cup with
the Buffalo Sabres and we've been down
that road many times and very close and
I think this is just another one in the
those long lists of things that have
happened in the city I grew up here I
was here during the Super Bowl years and
now I cover this team professionally and
and it hurts it hurts badly this morning
because again I think there's a sense of
if you weren't going to beat the Chiefs
this year if you weren't going to do it
now will you ever be able to do it well
that's what I kept coming back to that
there's no other player in modern-day
football that I feel more confident in
than Patrick Mahomes so even when the
team is not as good I there there's
still that confidence maybe we we
certainly had that with Brady we had
that probably with Joe Montana game on
the line you go yeah somehow and I still
don't have that yet with Josh Allen
where you go you know what and and I
thought he played pretty well I didn't
understand the game plan in the final in
the fourth quarter they started to throw
the ball where I thought they could they
could have kept running all night and
rush for over 200 yards so did M
McDermot talk about they tried to change
things up there in the fourth
quarter no I think what happened though
was um if you watch you know the game
the first half the bills were dominating
the line of scrimmage they were run for
over five yards a carry they they were
controlling the game with the Run game
chiefs made a nice adjustment in the in
the second half they they went from two
high to one high they put a guy in the
Box they were making sure the bills
couldn't run the ball they were they
were really kind of forcing the bills
weapons to beat them in the outside and
the bills couldn't win and when they did
win they had a couple drop passes right
I mean they took a couple shots down the
field step on Diggs Trent sherfield so I
don't think it was some major game plan
shift I think the Chiefs did a good job
of taking away the Run you know but but
on that note though I think the game
plan was you know the bills came into
this game so depleted on defense Dan
that I think the bills said look if we
can control the game on the ground and
keep Patrick Mahomes off the field and
have long drives and they did that seven
minute drives eight minute drives
unfortunately though the first one ends
in a field goal not a touchdown that
hurts you then you go three and out in
another series later that hurt you and
really at the end of the day you
couldn't stop the Chiefs and they were
just scoring every time which is why
they went for the fake field goal I'm
sorry the fake Punt and mcder said look
we just weren't stopping them um so and
then as far as Josh Allen's concerned I
thought he played one heck of a game
again this guy's been so good in the
playoffs I was doing the numbers this
morning Dan it's amazing to think he
started 10 playoff games this carees
five and five of course the record is
the record when you count passing
rushing and even one reception he had
for a touchdown a few years ago 330
yards a game he's accounted for 27
touchdowns and only four interceptions I
mean his numbers are remarkable it's
incredible that he has not been to a
Super Bowl yet and I think this is what
we do right we all know it we grew up in
Dan Marino and Jim Kelly and this is
what we do we it's the quarterback to
the quarterback Josh Allen if anybody
thinks that he is some sort of issue why
the bills haven't gotten this this or to
where they need to go then they haven't
watched because this is the only reason
this guy he's carrying this team on his
back like he kind of did last night the
weather is tolerable when you have
football but now that you don't have
football does it get colder s it gets
colder especially when you have a hockey
team that currently has the longest uh
NHL playoff drought going on and
normally we can turn our attention there
right I mean normally it's like okay
well football season it's over it kind
of things we got our Sabers but that
hasn't been the case for 11 12 years now
in the playoffs you know and we have uh
we have some nice things to do here in
the winter in Buffalo you got college
basketball around we got some skiing and
sledding and things like that but I
would say for sure our attention here in
Buffalo now turns to the offseason the
bills really kind of run the show here
and the Sabres do too when they're good
but yeah I'd say so I always say that
same thing Dan I'm like the worst months
really are like late January and into of
February so the longer the bills can go
on that helps all of our mental health
and the way we feel about things thank
you s we appreciate you joining us
anytime man thank you that's s capatio
he is the Bills beat reporter sideline
reporter for wgr sports radio he's been
doing that covering the bills for 13
years